Pollsters have been tracking America's reactions
to COVID since the pandemic began in March, 2020,
and we have covered their findings each month
in the AEI Polling Report. Axios/Ipsos recently
released their 59th weekly wave of results.
While concern has increased since the summer, 72%
in their December, 2021, poll said they plan to
see family or friends outside their households
during the winter holidays. 31% of those who
would see family or friends said that they
would see people who were unvaccinated. Despite
the emergence of the omicron variant, pollsters
note that few have increased the rate in which
they wear masks or social distance in public.
Fifty-four percent of employed people supported
their employer requiring all employees to be
vaccinated — forty-five percent were opposed — and
a third said that their employer had implemented
a vaccine mandate in recent weeks. In another
question, 51% supported making it illegal for
companies to deny service or employment to the
non-vaccinated, including 55% of Republicans,
and 46% of Democrats. How concerned are you about
the omicron variant? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.